[Music]
the key challenges we face in Europe at
the moment is a lack of air of airspace
capacity so we've got to do a number of
things in the years ahead to me the
biggest issue is to adopt a network
centric approach and to change the way
that we deal with the airspace
fragmentation in Europe commission set
up group of European aviation experts to
come with recommendations that would
define the future or let's say direction
of European atm and let's say the most
difficult or challenge actually was that
we have a holistic approach as holistic
as possible a key word is technology if
we really want to improve our system we
need to add more technology into our
etienne environment to make it more
efficient more flexible and more
customer oriented this is one of the
main lines we have proposed in the
report to embrace technology and to
foster automation so that we can better
cope with the challenges we have ahead
automation will have an influence staff
are the ones who are mostly affected by
technology because we are not computers
we are still humans but without staff
technology will not run there is one
principle described which is that the
SDM was created on an industry
partnership where the operational
stakeholders are part in the
decision-making process I think we
should put it into any other organized
organizational form which comes up now
in the future that these shareholders
are on executive and functional level
that they play their part that they take
responsibility and that they can make
decisions as well
we need a mandate from the Commission to
the network manager to start to work on
the implementation and so even this
summer will be better for the passengers
[Music]